seems three yeah I line it out hopefully
and not get worse yeah
if anybody can think of like a story you
really love that he skips your welcome
to the pokken you've all come to ask
questions yeah since I caused the
question yeah I guess that would be best
I repeat the question that's asked yeah
yeah cuz it won't be long yeah starting
back in to tell us the story of how
would I got here yes well I started out
by building airplanes in Toronto and
wasn't enjoying that and not also in the
automotive sector and so I was looking
for a career change and at that time I
was really looking for a clear sign you
know what I should be doing with my life
I was being drawn to the the healing
arts and I would have manufacturing but
at the same time I was having fabulous
success in manufacturing so it was quite
a difficult decision to make to go into
being a massage therapist from that but
that's the direction I was going so I
went off on a Vision Quest and came out
west to fast for four days and sit at
the top of a mountain and wait for a
clear answer and on my way to get my
final things together to go off on that
Vision Quest
that's when I was hit by a car while
riding a bicycle and you scold was
fracture and I woke up in the hospital
didn't know my name and where I was from
what year it was or what I used to do
for a living for that matter so so the
answer to my Vision Quest couldn't be
more clear I will then work in healing
mine and it'll take a long time so I was
in rehab for the next five years
full-time and until the Clark case
settled because there's a car accident
there's lawyers involved and private
investigators following around taking
pictures every well you do your rehab so
but at some point very early on I
decided I needed to take up dance I had
been doing Tai Chi prior to the accident
but dance was something I thought was
just an intuition I needed to do
something that was fun light-hearted and
and good for my balance because I had
such a balanced compromise especially on
my left side so that's why I started
dancing and shortly after that my
chiropractor said to me you just keep
doing what you're doing you're healing
faster than anybody's real realistic
expectations so just keep doing what
you're doing and within a couple of
years after the accidents when I made
the decision that I will build a dance
studio when this is all over I'll make a
dance studio so that's when they started
to doing in 2002 was headed west and
looked for a place to build to build a
studio and for many reasons I got driven
towards Los Guinea Island but most
notably it was because there's no
building inspectors here so I could do
whatever I wanted and that appealed to
me I wanted
experiment and in design and
construction I had no idea how big it
was going to be at the time and this is
all improvised so I thought I needed a
place just for a few friends to come and
dance and we would do do some Tai Chi
but then it just kept getting bigger and
bigger as I was building it and
redesigned to the point where well now
it's um it's a 10,000 square foot
building 1,000 square meters
you know 30 people are here this week
from all over the world we're in the
midst of a six-week long residency for
experienced dancers and contact
improvisation and people have come from
long ways to come and play with us here
and I'm quite honored today's one of
those days we don't do this particular
thing often but stuff like it
what's the design of the studio based on
aa couple of things it is very organic
that there is a painting of a bridge
from 12th century China called the
Rainbow Bridge and that's what I
designed the truss system off of it made
sense because when I figured out how
they did it
this went together really fast and easy
the building didn't get completed until
an hour before the first workshop
started but people came from all over
and they had no idea what they were
coming to there there was no photographs
of the building yet so they just
registered to do a dance workshop and
there was a full group it was over 25
people and then the building was
revealed now because of the internet
people see photographs of it everywhere
the studio is famous I remain anonymous
[Music]